[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN CIRULI: I want to
talk briefly about what
Istio does for you.
I'm not going to get
into the componentry that
make it all
possible, but there's
three real benefits to Istio,
and the first is observability.
Applications are distributed
now, they just are.
Even if you're just
running your application
in a single Kubernetes
cluster, in all likelihood,
to get more out of
your developers,
to be more productive, you've
gone to a micro services
architecture and
there's communication
between the services
and your application.
When there's communication
between services
and application,
it means that you
need to understand that
communication in order
to understand your application.
In order to understand why
it's performing the way
it's performing, in order to
make sure that the traffic is
going where you need it to.
So Istio offers ways to gather
telemetry, to gather logs,
and to gather traces
from every component
of your application,
every service,
so that you can understand it.
Second, it offers
operational agility.
It offers without
recompiling your application,
without changing anything
in your source code,
the ability to change
a retry policy,
to change a backup policy,
to redirect traffic
because one of your
back ends is slow,
to do a canary test to make
sure that you can roll out
a new version easily.
So it offers that
operational agility.
And the third benefit
is security, the ability
to encrypt all of your
traffic in transit,
and the ability to
use policy to control
which services can communicate
with other services.
And one thing that
we'll talk about later
but I'd like to
emphasize about Istio,
is that I consider Istio
very much an al a carte menu.
It has a lot of features.
It has a lot of components.
However, and however
daunting that
may sound at times,
one thing I like
to emphasize when we talk about
Istio is that it is a la carte.
And you can choose the
things that you want.
I talked to many
customers about Istio,
and I often say there's
no silver bullet.
There's not one feature
that everybody needs.
For some people, security.
All they want is security.
They want mTLS.
They need encryption
between their services.
They want authorization policy.
That's all they need, and
Istio gives them that.
Other people feel like they're
flying blind in Kubernetes,
and when their app
is running slow
they don't know why
it's running slow.
So that observability
is the right thing.
And for other people it's
that operational agility.
It's that they need to be able
to do a canary test in order
to release safely.
So it is an a la
carte menu, and you
can use the features
that are important to you
and just not use the other ones.
We talk a lot about
Kubernetes with Istio,
and we did start
with Kubernetes.
That was always where
we intended to start,
however it's not
just for Kubernetes.
We do run our control
plane in Kubernetes,
and there's some things
that are nice about it.
And the two things
in particular that
were nice about Kubernetes,
well, three things.
One is Kubernetes allowed us to
deploy a sidecar proxy easily
and transparently
without engineers
having to redo anything about
the way they do deployment.
Having that sidecar lets us
do all the magic of Istio.
Second, Kubernetes offers
a service registry.
So we know where
everything is running,
and when something
scales up we know that
and we can direct
traffic appropriately.
And thirdly, with
that sidecar proxy
it allows us to
do the networking
we need to make sure that
all the traffic into and out
of the service goes through it.
However, those problems are
solvable outside of Kubernetes,
also.
And we're working
with customers today
who are extending their service
measures by installing proxies
in VM based workloads.
And we even have
customers who are looking
at how they will do that to
even more legacy things, things
that are running in mainframes.
Another thing, the
service mesh if you
look at the Google Trends
graph on service mesh
it has certainly gone up a lot
in the last couple of years.
A lot of service
meshes are out there.
All of them are open source.
The thing that distinguishes
Istio more than anything else
is that this is the
one service mesh
project that a lot of the
industry is getting behind.
There are other service
measures each of which
is built by a company.
We started this with IBM,
we work very, very closely
with Lyft and
they're envoy proxy,
but Red Hat, VMware,
Cisco, and the list
goes on and on
behind companies who
have realized that
just like it's happened
with orchestration
and Kubernetes,
it will be better for our users
if we can all work together
on one technology.
And so this is the
service mesh that
has the most companies
behind it and has the most
momentum because of that.
And with that, I'm
going to turn it over
to Russ, who will tell you a
little bit about Autotrader.
RUSSELL WARMAN: Thanks Dan.
So we're based in the UK.
We're the UK version
of Autotrader.
And we are the UK's largest
automotive marketplace,
and our goal is about
leading the digital future
of that marketplace.
We're the 16th
biggest UK website,
and we've got something
in the region of 55
million cross platform visits.
And on average
we've got probably
around 450,000
vehicles advertised
on our platform, our
marketplace, each day.
And as you can see, we've got
around four times more auto
searches than Google have
on their platform, which
is a good start.
We've been around
for about 40 years.
And we've seen lots of
transformation through there.
We successfully migrated
all our revenues
from our print business
to digital back in 2013,
where we stopped
producing magazines.
And Karl and I were chatting
about this yesterday,
and we feel that we're almost
in the next phase of sort
of migration in terms
of becoming more cloud.
We've been building our private
cloud for probably six or seven
years, but we're now
in a sort of next stage
of that transformation
where we're starting
to take more cloud services.
We are a very values
driven organization.
We use a lot of data to
inform our decision making.
We like experiment
and then failing fast,
and we use technology
to enable us to do that.
And we try and avoid using it
because it's shiny and cool.
DAN CIRULI: One
thing I will say is
that the transformation
that's happened
in our industries over the
last decade, decade and a half
as industry after industry has
been changed by technology,
we've seen very large companies
get put out of business.
What's interesting
about Autotrader
and gives you a little insight
into how they view innovation
is that they didn't get put
out of business by someone
coming in and taking
your market digitally.
They realized what was happening
and with a very innovation
embracing culture have
established themselves
as they were a leader then,
and they're a leader now.
So I say this just
to say that they're
fostering a culture
of innovation,
and it's really paying off.
In fact, you might say it
kept in business, right?
So let's talk about where
you were a year or so ago
before you started
investigating Istio,
and what the situation was like
and why you got led into this.
So first, let's just
talk practically.
How big is your team, how
many developers do you have,
and how many
services do you have?
KARL STONEY: OK,
so great questions.
The number of services
that we have, like I'm sure
a lot of your organizations,
is constantly in flux.
We have new ones coming online
every day and going away,
but at any given
point in time it
floats between about
350 and 400 services.
It's a very micro
service architecture.
So if you think about
our main website
it's probably the easiest
way to visualize this path.
If you go in search for a car
on that you might hit seven,
eight, maybe nine different
services in the back end.
So we have a whole mesh
of things pieced together.
In terms of actual
infrastructure,
because I know there
will be a few of you
in here interested in that,
we have two big physical data
centers based over in
Manchester in the UK.
In those data centers we have
what we consider our oldest
platform to be,
which was a VMware
stack with servers that were
built using Chef and Puppet.
We have a tool which deploys
code onto those servers
but they were long live servers.
The next evolution
of that platform.
was our private cloud, which
Dan touched on a minute ago,
which was Phoenix based servers.
So every time we
did a deployment,
we got new servers as well.
So we're moving
in that direction.
That private cloud brings in
some standardization as well.
One of the problems that
we've got on premise
is all instances
of our applications
had two CPUs and
two gigs of RAM,
regardless of whether
or not they needed it.
So you might have
like a little node web
service which needs a
tenth of that but it
was just a standard amount
of CPU and RAM given.
In terms of developers
we've got around about 200,
would you say?
Around about 200 developers.
But we do have a relatively
centralized infrastructure
and operations team
that I'm part of,
which is a grand total
of about 20 people.
So you can see the ratio
of operations support
against developers.
DAN CIRULI: Yeah,
so that's good.
So you had several hundred
services, a couple hundred
developers, and a small
infrastructure and operations
team each.
10 or so, each of those, great.
And you mentioned cloud.
So you essentially built your
own private cloud, right?
RUSSELL WARMAN: Yes, right.
DAN CIRULI: And what
led you to do that?
RUSSELL WARMAN: We've moved
over the last six or seven
years from manual
deployments into auto deploy,
and we wanted to make sure
that as an application was
released we were releasing
the infrastructure
at the same time.
So getting more towards the
sort of Phoenix servers Karl
talked on before.
DAN CIRULI: And was it that
increased rate of deployment?
Is that what you
wanted, more agility?
RUSSELL WARMAN:
Yeah, absolutely.
We wanted to put the control
back in the developers hands
so they're not looking at the
infrastructure and operations
teams to be able to
deploy their applications.
We wanted them to be able
to do that themselves.
Smaller features, more
frequent releases,
that was the ambition.
DAN CIRULI: So no
one has to call Karl
and say spin me up a VM, I'm
going to install something.
Was it a Git based workflow?
RUSSELL WARMAN: Exactly.
DAN CIRULI: OK.
OK, great.
And how long did
a deployment take?
RUSSELL WARMAN: For some
of the older stuff, so
on the virtualization or
traditional virtualization
platform, it could
take a few hours.
For the private cloud it was
something like 10 minutes.
DAN CIRULI: OK.
RUSSELL WARMAN: And that
was with no manual work.
DAN CIRULI: OK.
So you had undergone a
transformation on your own.
You had you had seen the
need to do this by yourself.
OK, so now you've got a
couple hundred developers,
you have 10 people
in operations.
How did they know
what was going on?
RUSSELL WARMAN: So the
operations team pretty much
look after all the
monitoring for customer
facing applications, and
they're all done the same.
But the individual
micro services
are all monitored
differently, and the teams
had different logs and wrote
their own metrics for those.
And probably you can
explain a little bit on.
KARL STONEY: Yeah, sure.
So if you think
back to the graph
that you saw a minute ago
about our organization
and the transformation,
it's gone on
from a magazine business to
a fully digital business.
What happens generally
within those sorts of growths
is you get organic
growth of tooling.
So different teams pop
up different tools.
They're all trying to
solve similar problems.
What you end up with is
we've got the elastic stack,
we've got Graphite, we've
got Grafana, we've got Sensu,
we use SolarWinds.
The list goes on because all
of these teams, fundamentally
what they want to
be able to see is
the health of their
application, or applications
as I said before.
Seven, eight, nine services
to service that customer's
request.
They might be monitored in
three or four different ways.
So if you can think about
the operation teams problem
that they're getting an
alert at two in the morning
that the customer
facing websites
experiencing a high error rate,
trying to actually track down
the root cause of that
problem is super difficult.
DAN CIRULI: So different
operational tools,
different monitoring tools
for different services.
Yeah, I can see the
life of the ops person
would be pretty rough.
And what about security?
You do a lot of traffic between
these services obviously.
Any encryption on that?
KARL STONEY: No,
so actually this
is one of the main
drivers for Istio.
I know we're going to
touch on it a little bit,
but a lot of you
all know we do HTTPS
to the edge of our
infrastructure.
But the communication between
the services internally,
with inside the same area
of the network effectively,
was just HTTP with
AuthN and AuthC,
but it wasn't
encrypted in transit.
That was one of the
things that we really
wanted to tackle as well.
DAN CIRULI: What kind of
languages were you using?
KARL STONEY: I mean, we're
typically a Java shop.
On the really, really old
stuff, we've got a mixture.
We got some Python.
We've got some stuff
running on Windows.
But I'd probably say 90% Java
on the private cloud, which
is sort of middle evolution
of our platform, the one that
got the deployment times
down to about 10 minutes.
One of the ways that
we achieved that
was enforcing quite a
bit more standardization.
So the deployable
artifact for that platform
was a JAR, effectively.
So it was Java or
nothing on that platform.
DAN CIRULI: Right.
So developers would
check in the code,
and you had a pipeline
they would take that code,
generate a JAR, spin up a VM,
deploy that JAR to the VM,
right?
KARL STONEY: Yeah exactly that.
It would check it in, build
a JAR, post it to a service,
and it gets published out.
DAN CIRULI: Was Java right
for all the use cases?
KARL STONEY: Absolutely not.
But the thing that
developers will
do when faced with a
problem or a constraint,
they will work around it.
So what we find was happening
was that people, for example,
they were wanting to
run a simple single page
application that they've
written in Express, in Node,
or something like that.
They would embed
this Node service
into a Java build
process and into a JAR
just so that they could
deploy it onto the platform
because they want the
benefits of the platform.
They want the
standardization and they want
the quick deployment times.
The fact that they
have to use Java,
for them, it was a constraint
that was just causing pain.
DAN CIRULI: So it's
the Henry Ford rule.
Any language you want,
as long if it's Java.
OK, you already hinted at
this, but you've already
made some great strides.
Why did you start using Istio?
What made you want to do
this, or him want to do this.
Who's responsible for this?
RUSSELL WARMAN: So we had
a customer requirement
for a new service that
we were tendering for,
and they asked us to provide
end to end encryption.
And we tried to build it
into our new platform,
and we started a two week spike.
And then after about several
months worth of effort,
this guy gets super
frustrated and he just said,
I've had enough of this.
I think I can do
this a different way.
Can I try running it with Istio?
So I said OK, and then
two or three days later I
think he'd spun something up
and was able to demonstrate just
how easy it was to do
the end to end encryption
using Istio rather than trying
to build in the sidecar proxy
with our other platform.
DAN CIRULI: And you said
he spun something up.
Where was that?
KARL STONEY: I'll jump in.
Before I answer that question,
what we're actually doing
is running two parallel
streams of work.
So as Russ said, we were trying
to implement a sidecar model
onto our existing platform.
So when you've got a
standardized delivery platform,
which is that middle
one with the single JAR,
it's easier to add
something to that.
I wouldn't say easier though,
it still became a several months
process and we still weren't
successfully rolling it out.
The older platform, which
was a whole bunch of stuff
on Windows, et cetera, we just
we couldn't even do it there.
So just wanted to
call out that pain.
I couldn't see a light
at the end of the tunnel,
and that worried me,
which is kind of why
we started looking at Istio.
But I wanted to prove out that
Istio was going to give us
what we needed to do quickly.
I wanted to spike
it, effectively.
The quickest way for us
to do that at the time,
because we were involved in
Istio at 0.2 or something
back in the day, it was
to do on Kubernetes.
We didn't have
Kubernetes on premise,
so the quickest way for
me to spin up Kubernetes
without to worry about
managing stuff was on GKE.
So that's how we managed to
basically test out and prove
mutual TLS, on Istio, on GKE,
in the space of a week when
we've been battling with manual
implementation for months.
DAN CIRULI: OK.
So to sum up where you were,
you had somewhere between 300
and 400 micro services.
You had a couple hundred
developers, 10 people in ops,
no encryption between
services, and you
needed encryption all the way.
You had wasted some time
building mTLS yourself.
VM-based, a couple CPUs
to everything, no matter
how big it was.
Using JAR for
essentially everything.
So that's where you were.
You did a POC on
Istio, you found out
this can solve your problem.
And what's interesting here is
that what you needed was mTLS.
Implementing Istio on Kubernetes
was just the fastest way
to get that to happen.
And the fastest way to
get Kubernetes to happen
was to use GKE, right?
OK, you prove that it happened,
let's talk about the decisions
you made.
From that point you call
him up and you say Russ,
I have good news.
I can get this to work, and
I can get it to work fast.
You had to make some decisions.
Which features out of
Istio did you need?
KARL STONEY: So the
Istio implementation
was driven out of the
requirement for mTLS
as we've already said.
So that was the first thing
we wanted to prove out,
which we did very easily.
It was a case of turning it on.
We didn't have to
think about it.
However, what we were also doing
because we were running on GKE
and we were going
to public cloud,
we were bundling in,
not just deploying
Istio, but effectively
a private cloud
to public cloud migration.
That's a lot of change.
As I mentioned
earlier on we didn't
have a great amount of
insight into applications
from an observability
perspective
on the current stack,
and we had a whole bunch
of different tools.
So if we're moving things from
on premise to public cloud
and we're implementing
Istio and we're
sticking it into containers.
How do we know
it's even working?
So that was where the
uniform observability
started to pull in as well as.
We need to be able to
observe these applications
and these collection
of services,
and we decided to have a like
a multi cloud model as well.
So some stuff on premise,
some stuff in Google,
we've got stuff in Amazon.
We're all over the place.
We needed a consistent
view to know
that as we move these
things, we don't break them.
So they were the two
real features for us.
DAN CIRULI: And the advanced
networking wasn't a driver.
In fact, I don't think you've
implemented anything really.
KARL STONEY: We're not
really using it, no.
It's there in the
back of our minds
is a feature that we
know we might do one day,
but it's a great
example of where we just
didn't need to right now.
DAN CIRULI: That's great, fine.
And so you move to containers.
You said something
earlier, the JAR
was your unit of deployment.
What's your unit deployment now?
KARL STONEY: A container.
So as I've touched on already,
people were working around
the single JAR problem
by just embedding stuff
in really crazy
ways, and we wanted
to remove that constraint.
So the deployable artifact
on the latest version
of our platform.
When I say our platform by the
way, just so everyone's clear,
I mean we've built a platform
as a service like a Heroku style
model on top of GKE and
Istio and the public cloud
providers, et cetera
to give that developer
that standard interface where
they can do deployments really
easily.
So yeah, our deployable
artifact is now
a container, which
is great because it
means these Java
apps that are just
running single page
Express servers can just
be expressed now.
But we monitor them by box
in exactly the same way.
DAN CIRULI: And of course
kind of implicit, as you said,
you moved.
You're still running a cloud.
It felt like a cloud before
because the developers didn't
touch infrastructure,
but now it's GKE.
Any notes on running Kubernetes?
Did you really think about
installing and running
Kubernetes on prem, or
was GKE an obvious choice?
RUSSELL WARMAN: So we tried
to run other things on prem
and failed, and
decided that we'd
use cloud services instead.
So we had a very
brief conversation.
I think it lasted
about 10 minutes,
and we decided that we
should just use Google.
It just made absolute
sense to do it.
DAN CIRULI: So for example
you would run Hadoop clusters,
right?
RUSSELL WARMAN: We tried to.
DAN CIRULI: Do you still
do that, or do you not?
RUSSELL WARMAN: Nope.
DAN CIRULI: OK.
So you've realized that
some of these services, it's
just easier to have someone
else run it for you.
RUSSELL WARMAN: Absolutely.
DAN CIRULI: And Kubernetes
fell in that bucket?
RUSSELL WARMAN: Yeah.
We don't want to manage
the complexity of upgrades
and sorting all those.
That level just doesn't
give any benefit to us
as an organization,
so we'd rather
take it as a money service.
DAN CIRULI: So
you're the engineer,
you say this is going to happen.
You're the head
of infrastructure.
You say I believe you.
Do you have to tell anyone
above you, hey by the way
as part of solving this
problem for the customer we're
going to start running
things in the cloud?
RUSSELL WARMAN: So our strategy
has been to be cloud native,
and we've not defined whether
it would be private or public.
And when we started
demonstrating
some of the features
and the benefits
that we got from using GKE,
it was really, really easy
to justify the decision as
to why we would do that.
So there wasn't really
a lot of conversation.
I think people just
understood the benefits
and saw that it was
the right thing to do.
DAN CIRULI: So
when I hear people
talk about adopting this,
people are concerned a lot
with friction.
You have 200 developers.
Kubernetes, factoring
Istio on top of that,
we're talking about a lot
of YAML, a lot of CRDs.
How much YAML do your
developers have to deal with?
KARL STONEY: This is a
really interesting question
because it was one
of the bigger, well,
it could have been
one of the bigger pain
points for
implementing Kubernetes
and Istio, et cetera.
For one service to get
deployed onto our platform,
as I described it before there's
about 20 different YAML files
that get generated.
So you've got all of
the Kubernetes service
manifest deployments,
then you've
got all your Istio components.
You've got virtual services,
destination rules, side cars.
We automate DNS and
TLS as well, so you've
got certificates,
certificate requests, Ingress
configurations.
So there's just tons
and tons of them.
And if you think about where
we were, we were in a position
where developers don't think
about the infrastructure,
they build a JAR and
they want that JAR
to run on some infrastructure.
So we could just
not scale them up
within any sort of
reasonable time frame on all
of these different APIs
because that's fundamentally
what they are.
And some of those APIs were
under very rapid change.
Like I said earlier
on, we were involved
in Istio very, very early
doors so we didn't want
to push that onto the teams.
So your answer is a lot of YAML.
DAN CIRULI: But your
developers aren't
writing that YAML, right?
KARL STONEY: Correct.
So the approach
that we've gone down
and I've been chatting to
a few of the companies who
are doing this at the moment.
We've abstracted them
from that concern.
They just provide us
with a single YAML
file, which has some key
aspects about their application.
So it's like a minimum amount of
instances that they should run,
the name of the image
that we should be running,
some information about
the health checks.
It exposes affinities
if they want
to run their other applications.
Bit of metadata about the
service, because we have
a service catalog and stuff.
And firewall policy, so
what is going to talk to you
and what do you talk to.
And from that behind
the scenes, the platform
that infrastructure and
operations are responsible for
generates and manages
all that other YAML.
And that's worked
really well for us.
DAN CIRULI: So they still have
they interface with this system
through the CICD pipeline,
and they have one config file.
You generate all the right
Kubernetes and Istio files.
I think that's a
really important point.
So you had 350 services.
Did you do this one day, did
you just throw them all in?
How is the progression?
KARL STONEY: Overnight.
[LAUGHTER]
RUSSELL WARMAN: So,
we've started cherry
picking some of the services.
So the things that were
already on our private cloud,
they'd been built to be cloud
native, so we've moved some
of those applications across.
And that gave people
the confidence
that it was going to work.
And then, in parallel
with that, we
started moving some
of the applications,
or trying to move some
applications that historically
proved difficult
because they didn't
conform to the single JAR.
So we started working
on those in parallel
to try and overcome any of the
problems that we might face.
DAN CIRULI: So
you cherry picked.
You cherry picked
some easy ones,
but you cherry picked
some thorny ones too?
RUSSELL WARMAN: Yeah.
DAN CIRULI: OK.
That's a good strategy.
KARL STONEY: This is just
to add something to that one
actually if you don't mind.
So just to give you an idea
about some of the more gnarly
stuff, we've got a we've got
some containers now that are
running .NET Core, so we had
some Windows based applications
before.
So we take that and use one of
those difficult applications
to drive out capabilities
that we wanted
to deliver on the
platform and that we
wanted to expose from Istio.
So it's a really
iterative approach
that difficult applications
were driving the features,
rather than just trying to
build all the features up front
and then release the platform.
DAN CIRULI: So the
process was essentially
you did a POC, you
built out some infra,
you did an initial
rollout, and yeah.
And this became an
iterative thing then
you rolled out to a
class of applications,
you found one that wouldn't fit.
You would add capabilities.
So the implementation,
as it went
to sum up the
implementation, you
didn't train your developers
on Istio and Kubernetes.
You trained your infrastructure
and ops team, right?
These people do it, your
infrastructure team.
You had to build a
CICD pipeline that
deployed the Kubernetes GKE.
Your ops team now
is trained on, I
don't think we
had a slide on it,
but in your new monitoring
infrastructure right?
KARL STONEY: Yeah, so the way
that our ops team work is they
generally respond to those.
They're first line
support in a lot of ways.
So it's like an
application is misbehaving
or a customers got an
impacting scenario.
So the symptoms that they
see on all of these platforms
are the same.
You know, it's a
customer impacting event.
But what we needed
to train them up in
is, well, how do I debug
that in a container world
where I might have
a multi-tenant host.
So we ended up building tooling.
I think one of them
is called Monkeynetes,
which just runs on our clusters
and generally just misbehaves,
and triggers alerts.
And the ops teams
pick those things up.
And they just get
practiced right.
You know, an
applications misbehaving
and how do I look at its logs?
You know, it's different.
It's like how do I get
onto the box, which
is the most common
question, I was like, well,
there isn't a box per se.
So you got to think about
those sorts of things.
DAN CIRULI: Are you
running Prometheus?
KARL STONEY: Yes.
I can't remember if we had
a slide on standardized.
DAN CIRULI: I can't remember.
Do we have a slide on that?
KARL STONEY: Well we can talk
about and they will skip past.
DAN CIRULI: We'll make
sure we get to it.
How far along are you?
KARL STONEY: So, yeah.
What, did you
check this morning?
184 applications
live out of 350.
And we really only start ramping
this up about six months ago.
Six to nine months,
something like that.
So we were well on the way.
DAN CIRULI: So
you're about halfway.
I'm doing my math, it's rough
but you're about halfway there.
And how much traffic is going
to those Kubernetes based
services?
KARL STONEY: When you asked me
this question the other day,
because obviously we did
a little bit of prep,
it's a great question
because I couldn't answer it
on the old platform, and this
is the observability aspect.
It's like if you
came to me and said
Karl, how much HTTP
traffic have we
done on our private cloud in the
last 24 hours, I'd go not sure.
I could probably
go and aggregate
all of the logs from all of
the applications running there
and come up with some value
but it would take me ages.
But I think I answered
this question for you
by looking at the Istio
statistics in about 10 seconds.
So in the last 24 hours we've
done about 80 million HTTP
requests, and the overall
success rate of those requests
was like 99.998% at the time.
And that failure rate
was covered by retries,
there was no client
impacts in events.
So I'm just able to answer
these questions in moments
DAN CIRULI: That's great.
And security?
KARL STONEY: Turn it
on, it just works.
DAN CIRULI: mTLS on everything?
KARL STONEY: Yeah.
So a few people who've been
doing Istio implementations.
Some are trying to bring in
mTLS as a phased approach.
Some people are already
running GKE clusters
and they're out
in Istio and then
they're trying to
bring in a bit of mTLS.
We did mTLS mandated
from the offset.
I do believe I made
things a little bit easier
for us because we weren't
having to mix and match
different policies.
DAN CIRULI: So you
run in strict mode?
KARL STONEY: Strict mode, yeah.
DAN CIRULI: And what are
you doing for authorization?
KARL STONEY: We actually have
our own internal authentication
and authorization
services that run
across all of our platforms.
So we're not leveraging any
of the Istio components there.
We just continue to
use our existing stuff.
DAN CIRULI: OK.
So we did have a
slide on visibility.
So you're running
Prometheus, do you
run one instance of
Prometheus and everybody
sends data to it
through a Mixer adapter?
KARL STONEY: Yeah, so we have
we have several instances
of Prometheus, but when you
think about applications that
are deployed onto the
delivery platform,
so the ones that fit
the standard model,
there is just one
main Prometheus.
The interesting thing that we've
done though with Prometheus
is we've got all of the
Istio metrics going into it.
We've got the Kubernetes
metrics going into it.
But we've also standardized
other disciplines
within the business, such as
database engineers, et cetera.
They're all sending
Prometheus metrics in now.
So we actually have
a single source
of truth for the
state of our platform
from a lot of
different perspectives.
So if you remember
that big list of stuff
that I read out before
on the new platform,
it's just two tools.
We've built a couple of
additional alerting things
on top of that.
So we've got like a
chat ops interface
or when Istio detects a
higher than normal error
rate for an application
over the last 20 minutes
people can own
that, wheeling that
through to Runbox, et cetera.
So we've got a much more
consolidated view of the world
now.
DAN CIRULI: Has it made the life
of the operations team better?
Are they happier people?
KARL STONEY: They're not here
but I'll speak on their behalf.
I think they'd be
saying definitely.
DAN CIRULI: OK.
KARL STONEY: Great job.
DAN CIRULI: That's good to know.
And that Prometheus, is it
running in the same Kubernetes
cluster?
KARL STONEY: It is, yeah.
Just for no real reason
though, to be honest.
DAN CIRULI: Right.
You run one big cluster?
KARL STONEY: Yes,
we do actually.
That's another
interesting point.
So I know a lot of people
doing smaller clusters.
So we have one large
cluster per environment.
So we have testing
dev, pre-prod.
Everything in all of those
things gets replicated.
So separate GCP
projects, separate VPCs,
separate Kubernetes cluster,
separate firewall rules,
everything.
So it's all promoted across.
So yeah, big cluster
per environment.
We do have some other clusters.
We have CICD style
clusters which can access
all of those environments.
And we run an
elastic stack on GKE
as well, that's a
separate cluster.
But largely, yeah.
DAN CIRULI: OK.
Can you talk about how
big that cluster is?
Do you know how many nodes?
KARL STONEY: I think it was
about 400 CPUs, 800 gig of RAM
per environment at the
moment, of the top of my head.
DAN CIRULI: OK.
And we talked a little
bit about this before,
but obviously now you can put
whatever you want in that JAR.
The JAR is not a JAR anymore.
It's a container and you can
fill it with whatever you want.
Do you find people doing that?
KARL STONEY: Absolutely.
So if you think about the build
time and also the startup time.
I don't know how many of
you work with Java in here,
it can be a little bit
slower than just a node up
which just has a one
module, effectively.
And then it starts
almost instantaneously.
So developer teams,
they are switching out
these big JARs where they
don't need them anymore
because they get a faster
deployment process.
They get quicker start times.
We've had a couple
of product teams
that have been able to take
advantage of technologies
that they wouldn't have
been able to use before,
like GraphQL for example.
It's not written in Java.
So they can suddenly
deploy these things
and get ideas into production
and test things out
at an extremely low cost.
DAN CIRULI: Right.
KARL STONEY: And in
fact test things out
that they just
couldn't test before.
DAN CIRULI: That's fantastic.
RUSSELL WARMAN: Sorry, I'd
just like to add to that.
We were doing a
migration a few weeks ago
and it was for our launch
of our new price packages,
and partway through we
communicated to about 500
of our customers that we
were doing this change,
and we hit a little bug.
And it was about 4
o'clock in the afternoon
and I think it took you
about two hours or something
to write and deploy an
application to fix that.
That meant that we didn't have
to go back and communicate
to 500 of our customers
that we were going to have
to back out our release.
So it's just that
these capabilities just
weren't there before.
KARL STONEY: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSSELL WARMAN: Absolutely.
DAN CIRULI: That's fantastic.
So you talked about visibility
into your service traffic
and which services are
talking to which, et cetera.
What the requests per second
is on any given service.
But you also have visibility
into resource consumption now.
So talk about how that has
changed your efficiency.
RUSSELL WARMAN: So as
Karl said, everything
used to be provisioned with
two CPU's and two gig of RAM.
Now what we're seeing
through the platform
is that we've just got greater
visibility of how much resource
it's actually needing.
So we'd migrate applications
up exactly as they
were and then rightsize them.
And in a lot of instances,
we were probably
reducing it by about half.
And increasingly
what we're stating
is we'd probably need about 60%
to 70% less resources in GKE
than we did on prem.
So it's about 0.3 of a
core, around a gig of RAM,
and some of those then
will be changed accordingly
DAN CIRULI: OK.
Who makes sure that
a given service has
the right amount of resource?
Is the ops team doing that?
KARL STONEY: No.
So one of the changes that these
platforms actually brought in,
so if you remember before
they just published a JAR.
Now they're responsible
for the Docker file
and also that manifest file.
The CPU and RAM there is
editable by the product teams.
It's checked into
their Git repo.
It's also editable by the ops
engineers or the infrastructure
engineers.
Anybody can check into
that repo effectively
and make that change.
I
Think the key thing
to point out is now
everybody has the visibility
in order to make an informed
change, whereas before it
was a little bit shooting
in the dark.
So what we're
increasingly seeing
is operations teams and the
development teams sitting
together looking at
the graphs, looking
at the performance
of the application,
looking at infrastructure
statistics,
and making those
changes together.
Whereas before it used to
be very over the fence,
so it's actually pushing a more
dev ops model which is great.
DAN CIRULI: And cost.
So you're renting space
in a data center, right?
Now you're writing us
a check every month.
There are all kinds of
implications for cost.
How does your boss
think about that?
RUSSELL WARMAN: I
guess ultimately what
they're looking for is
some confidence that we've
got a plan to move out
of our data centers,
consolidate our
workloads in the cloud.
And we're being quite
aggressive in that migration.
So we have an ambition to
do it in 18 months and then
once we've done
that, we'll start
looking to reduce our footprint
on physical data centers.
DAN CIRULI: So you'll start
renting less space as you can.
What's interesting here is that
your cost was not your driver
for doing this.
Your reason for doing
this was mTLS, ultimately.
RUSSELL WARMAN: Absolutely.
DAN CIRULI: In the
end, do you think
that because of the
reduction in footprint
is it going to be cheaper?
RUSSELL WARMAN: I'm not making
any commitments on that.
DAN CIRULI: OK.
So that's interesting, but
the innovation is good, right?
RUSSELL WARMAN: I think
DAN CIRULI: It was
never driven by cost,
it still won't be
driven by cost.
RUSSELL WARMAN:
No, we don't think
it's going to cost us any
more, but what we do know
is that it will give
us greater capability
than we could provision
within our own data centers.
So, Karl touched on it before
in terms of operational agility.
The benefits that we get
from running GKE just far
outweigh way to trying
to do that on prem.
DAN CIRULI: Right.
KARL STONEY: I think there is
an interesting point though as
well, and it's if we had
like for like infrastructure,
like the same number of
applications and stuff,
probably it would.
But because of the new
capabilities that we've got,
we're building more apps.
So it's going to end up probably
costing us a little bit more,
but that's because we're
delivering more capabilities.
DAN CIRULI: So you're
also running Istio now
in that cluster, right?
So you're running Mixer, Pilot,
you're running a sidecar.
Do you know how much
it's costing you?
KARL STONEY: Yeah, so I actually
calculated this the other day.
It's about CPU and RAM
utilization on our cluster.
Bearing in mind we are doing
mTLS, which is heavyweight
everywhere, about 5%
of our CPU and RAM
is used towards the
Istio control plane.
Because it's an
opex model and we
know how much CPU and RAM
costs on Google Cloud,
we've worked out that
it costs us about $4
per service, as in per
application per month
to get all of those
capabilities of Istio.
DAN CIRULI: So there's some
invisibility that you have.
It's kind of incredible
that you can calculate that.
KARL STONEY: I
could never tell you
anything like that on premise.
DAN CIRULI: OK,
so what do you use
when you look at this project?
And we'll get to some
numbers in a minute,
but how do you measure success?
How do you know if
this project succeeded?
It's not reduced cost.
Obviously mTLS, there's
one thing, but how else?
Are there any metrics
you would use?
RUSSELL WARMAN: So the
frequency of deployments
is the big thing
for us, making sure
that our development
teams can release more
frequently and more safely.
So not having customer
impact is absolutely
the measures of success for us.
DAN CIRULI: Frequently
of deployment,
and the success of
those deployments.
Conveniently, Russ
provided me with some data
that we've thrown up here now.
You track the number of
deployments that you do.
RUSSELL WARMAN: Yeah.
So we've been tracking this,
as you can see, back to 2011,
I think it is.
This shows the
journey that we've
been on from manual deployment
through to auto deploy
and now as we've started
moving onto the new platform.
So you can see the Karl
effect there in there.
DAN CIRULI: The Karl effect.
[LAUGHTER]
RUSSELL WARMAN: Yeah.
DAN CIRULI: I mean this is
an almost unbelievable graph,
but I saw the numbers myself.
So the rate at which
your developers
can get code into production
and get a new feature out
has increased dramatically.
RUSSELL WARMAN: Yeah, and this
year we're predicting also,
this coming financial year.
We went from April to March.
We're predicting that that
number is going to hit 30,000.
DAN CIRULI: So doubling
again after quadrupling
in the last couple of years.
How many of those are failing?
RUSSELL WARMAN: Well you see
the numbers are just going down.
Year on year we're
getting more confident
that the platform is capable
of supporting more change,
but it's not impacting
our customers at all.
DAN CIRULI: This is
not a percentage.
This is raw number.
RUSSELL WARMAN: This is
absolutely raw numbers.
DAN CIRULI: So as we saw
that number of deployments
go way up, you've seen the
number of failing deployments.
This increased visibility,
what do you attribute that?
KARL STONEY: So,
I actually think
the main driver behind
this is because it's
so quick to deploy now.
I mean, literally you
can go from a change
into production in
a couple of minutes.
People are just
releasing more frequently
and doing smaller changes,
whereas before if it takes
say two, three hours
to do a release
they'll just bundle up more.
And then those things go
wrong more, basically.
DAN CIRULI: So when we look
on this on a percentage basis,
we've gone from four out
of every 100 deployments
having a problem to two out
of every 1,000 deployments
having a problem.
It's an impressive
thing that you've done.
So the status today,
you're halfway through.
You've got about half your
services running, all of them
with secure traffic.
You've reduced the
footprint for most of them.
Obviously you're deploying
a lot very successfully,
and we gave you a new
feature recently in 1.1,
and you had to roll that out.
How long did that take?
KARL STONEY: So in order
to get that feature out,
we had to redeploy
every application.
I think it took two
of our engineers
to implement the
feature and roll out
every app about three hours.
DAN CIRULI: So they changed
their CICD pipeline.
KARL STONEY: Yes.
We actually changed the
platform because the platform
is deployed in the
same way as, actually,
all of the applications.
So change the platform,
implement the new Istio feature
behind the abstraction, roll
out the applications in order
to pull in that new feature.
Yes, very quick.
DAN CIRULI: Yeah.
So if you want to get
started with Istio,
obviously it's an
open source project.
You can go to istio.io, you
can install it yourself.
On GKE we do have an
automated installer which
will take open source Istio and
plop that right on to your--
that's my animation
right there--
plop that onto your GKE cluster.
You can choose whether
or not you want mTLS.
It will automatically send
your metrics to Stackdriver.
You can plug in your own
Mixer adapters as well.
It's a great way to get started.
We do have a lot of people
who are using it now.
We not only do the installation,
but we will do upgrades for you
as well.
So when a new GKE
version comes out,
if there's a new
version of Istio,
we will automatically
upgrade that for you too.
It's not necessarily for
every production deployment
it does constrain which features
of Istio you can change.
If you need more flexibility
than it gives you,
it's not hard to install
Istio yourself as you learned.
And of course with the
Anthos announcement
yesterday, one of the
key components in Anthos
is service match
so we are working
on productized versions
of managed versions of all
the services as well.
So Istio will be included,
or some brand name version
of Istio, will be
included with Anthos.
And as an open source
project, you're
welcome to join the community.
We have community meetings every
two weeks when people come in.
And it's largely users, not
people who are contributing
to Istio, so I encourage that.
So thank you very much
everyone, please do rate.
Thank you to the crew in
the back for your help.
Have a good conference.
[MUSIC PLAYING]